bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro de check up votre
magazine santé bien-être ce mois ci nous
partirons à la découverte des techniques
de massage pour bébé ou l'instructrice
donne des cours aux parents à montigny
le bretonneux
nous irons ensuite à la rencontre d'une
yvelinoise au service des personnes
touchées par le cancer
elle leur propose des cours de gym
adaptée mais tout d'abord direction
trappe à l'hôpital privé de l'ouest
parisien des équipes travaillent
d'arrache-pied tous les jours pour
assurer la santé et le bien être de
leurs patients ce mois ci nous nous
sommes immergés dans le quotidien du
service dialyses à la rencontre des
néphrologues et des infirmières les
images sont signés elodie moines 12h30
la selle d'attentes de l'unité de
dialyse se remplit les patients ont
leurs habitudes et ils viennent ici
trois fois par semaine pour des séances
de quatre heures forcément ça crée des
liens ils finissent tous par se
connaître
l'infirmière prend le patient en charge
elle installe vérifie sa tension puis le
branchant l'appareil elles piquent le
patient à deux reprises sur le même bras
une aiguille artérielle et une aiguille
veineuse et nîmes qu'on appelle la terre
donc par ou le sang va être tirée
et nîmes qu'on appelle la veine ou le
sang va être restitué le sang du patient
en insuffisance rénale va faire tout un
circuit pour arriver dans le rein
artificiel géré par la machine là où
vont être filtrés les déchets et l'excès
d'eau le sang une fois nettoyée et
filtrer va repartir dans le corps du
patient via la ligne veineuse c'est le
principe de l'hémodialyse une boucle qui
dure quatre heures comme le monsieur
nury inclut tous les déchets organiques
s'accumulent ainsi que le potassium
ainsi que toute l'eau qui boit du coup
pour éviter des problèmes on enlève donc
l'excès d'eau pendant quatre heures et
tous les déchets sont filtrées
confondues vitré personnes
pompey façon impressionnante
sur saint divy franck et dialysés depuis
bientôt deux ans depuis ce temps-là
l'improvisation n'a plus sa place
on se sent complètement immobilisés
quand c'est très difficile de voyager
d'aller dans la famille d'excédent mais
ce qu'il faut on peut le faire mais il
faut réserver très longtemps à l'avancé
avec une précision quand je pars en
bretagne parce que j'y vais quelquefois
je suis obligé de me réserver si mort
avant en donnant le jour et l'heure de
la dernière dialyse ici quand des
associations permettent en effet de
prendre en charge la dialyse des
touristes les il en existe peu et il
faut prévoir
franck espère pouvoir être greffé un
jour l'uci est arrivé ici il y a cinq
ans elle travaille trois jours par
semaine des journées de 12 heures plus
deux soirs par mois
on crée une relation avec des habitudes
on les connaît on connaît leur vie on
connaît ce moi aussi ça comment réagit
puis après aussi pour un aspect
technique c'est à dire que la dialyse
faut apprendre les machines pour
apprendre la spécificité de piqué dans
une fistule ces deux aspects venir ici
l'échelle se déplacent ici trois fois
par semaine depuis 2011 bout de 4-5 ans
comment j'ai un peu tous se connaître
savoir ce qu'on a fait ce qu'on a
fabriqué leurs violons l'ambiance une
bonne ambiance est bonne ça crée
beaucoup de liens beaucoup de liens
entre patients dans l'autre groupe toto
- et puis on a le plaisir au moins ça
c'est c'est très important on a le
plaisir de se revoir tous les matins
enfin tous les midis quand on vient en
dialyse
oui on se retrouve en est on est bien
bien prochain et puis avec les
infirmières aussi parce qu'elle sent
vraiment très sympa l'insuffisance
rénale empêche les reins de remplir
pleinement leurs fonctions vitales
éliminer les déchets toxiques produits
par l'organisme maintenir la bonne
quantité d'eau dans le corps le bon
équilibre des minéraux ou encore
produire des hormones enzymes et
vitamines autant de rôles essentiels qui
ne sont plus correctement assurée par
les reins de tous ces patients ils sont
au stade de 5 sur 5 et des maladies
rénales chroniques
c'est des patients et pour un régime
très strict c'est à dire qu'ils peuvent
pas cumuler l'eau donc ils ont en
restriction hydrique ils ont droit à
environ une petite bouteille d'eau par
jour pour pas être trop d'eau sinon
c'est le rideau ap c'est à dire le thème
et guy dupont l'eau s'accumule dans les
poumons il en fait il se doit en tant
qu'infirmière lucie suit les
recommandations du néphrologue
c'est lui qui part à mettre tout ce
qu'elle doit faire pendant la séance et
en fonction de chaque patient ensemble
il collabore aussi avec une
diététicienne un véritable travail
d'équipé
le service de dialyse existe depuis une
quinzaine d'années à l'hôpital privé de
l'ouest parisien de trappes 3
néphrologue se partagent le travail en
traitant les maladies
e
en rapport par exemple avec une maladie
de systèmes une hypertension artérielle
un diabète qui retentit sur le rhin et
qui conduit à l'insuffisance rénale
on y va allez c'est parti
le lait frolov ne travaille pas
seulement aux salles de dialyse il
reçoit aussi les patients en
consultation généralement envoyés ici
par leur médecin traitant
bon comment ça va se fatiguer manque
d'appétit actuellement en france on
compte un peu moins de 80 mille
personnes dialysées ou greffe est
l'objectif du néphrologue et de les
dépister au plus tôt pour éviter les
complications la sémiologie rénale est
extrêmement ça sait où on est hyper
tendu on a un peu de protéines dans les
urines on a du sens à leur hymne
on a un dosage de créatinine qui est un
peu anormal qui commence à monter un
petit peu la créatine c'est un marqueur
de l'insuffisance rénale parce que elle
est produite par le muscle est éliminé
par le rein afin de ralentir voire
stopper l'évolution de l'affection
raynal le néphrologue et met en place
des mesures de prévention
s'il ya un diabète c'est le meilleur
compromis possible du diabète
finalement en travaillant conjointement
avec le diabétologue avec le médecin
traitant une hypertension artérielle
on travaille conjointement avec le
cardiologue le médecin traitant pour
surveiller et contrôler est traitée une
hypertension artérielle des infections
urinaires des problèmes de lithiase on
va travailler avec l'urologue c'est un
métier d'interface le métier néphrologue
un métier d'interface qui luttent chaque
jour contre la pénurie de greffons
disponibles pour les insuffisants rénaux
chaque année dix mille personnes des
marins traitement par dialyse
alors que moins de 3000 bénéficie d'une
greffe certains optent aussi pour une
autre solution celle du traitement à
domicile avec la dialyse péritonéale une
technique bien moins développés pour le
moment lucie et puis donc c'est la
première séance
maryline querrey est infirmière
puéricultrice
elle a suivi la formation de
l'association française du massage pour
bébé et propose depuis des ateliers
collectifs à montigny le bretonneux
elodie moines pour les images vous
prêter attention à la position de vos
pieds de vos jambes ce lundi matin à
montigny le bretonneux la séance de
massage bébé démarre par une étape
primordiale la relaxation des mamans
pendant plus d'une heure elles vont
ensuite stimuler tous les sens du bébé à
l'aide de gestes précis
les bénéfices sont nombreux au niveau du
ventre le massage a des vertus anti
coliques et s'ils ne font pas forcément
leur nuit les bébés auront au moins un
sommeil de meilleure qualité
est ce que tu veux bien que tu m as les
gens en angola avant de démarrer le
massage les mamans demande toujours
l'autorisation à leurs enfants
les séances peuvent démarrer dans les
semaines qui suivent la naissance
jusqu'à l'âge de 1 an sauf pour les
enfants porteurs de handicaps où il n'y
a pas de limite d'âge pendant le massage
on va apprendre aux parents à observer
leur bébé et du coup à regarder à
repérer les moments où il est disponible
pour le massage ou pas et on voit la
communication entre les parents qui
s'affine et qui vient de plus en plus
fluide et du coup ça ça va renforcer le
lien d'attachement entre les bébés et
leurs parents pour les mamans c'est
aussi un temps privilégié durant lequel
elles prennent du temps pour se poser
souvent elles sont bien prises en charge
pendant pendant toute leur grossesse à
la maternité
et puis quand elle rentre à la maison
avec leur bébé
bah c'est là qu'elle se retrouve tout
seul alors qu'elles ont plein de
questions plein d'interrogations et du
coup pendant les massages passé elle
retrouve un petit peu cette cette
convivialité sait-on des changes de
partage qui leur fait vraiment du bien
ça me rassure parce que moi c'est mon
premier bébé est en fait j'avais un peu
peur d'eux comment le prendre
est ce que je le touche et trop brusque
et moi ou pas assez avec le massage mais
c'est une approche du toucher et aux six
mois je peux observer beaucoup les
mamans autour voir comment elle faisait
et ben c'est rassurant de voir comment
les autres font voilà c'est un temps
qu'on passe ensemble et voilà on échange
on a donc c'est effectivement par le
massage par le corps par le regard
maryline quéré propose des sessions de
cinq séances pour une centaine d'euros
chacune est consacrée à l'apprentissage
de mouvement sur une partie du corps
de quoi pouvoir par la suite les
réaliser régulièrement chez soi à
domicile
à son chant le mardi et dans le parc du
château de rambouillet le jeudi deux
rendez vous hebdomadaires que
marie-dominique tournier à nîmes pour
les femmes et les hommes atteints d'un
cancer
elle a démarré son activité il y a
quatre mois et compte déjà quelques
adeptes
patrick 6 mai pour les images au parc du
château de rambouillet c'est le rituel
du jeudi
marie-dominique tournier propose une
marche adapté aux personnes atteintes
d'un cancer pendant ou après les
traitements et sans limite d'âge
je vais écouter les gens voyez pas ce
que vous allez voir des gens qui sont en
traitement qui vont venir avec moi vous
allez avoir des gens guéri voilà donc en
rémission qui vont venir aussi leur sens
tu n es pas la même main
marie-dominique donne des cours depuis
quatre mois dans les yvelines des
séances ceux qui évoluent sur un
trimestre et qui procure un réel
bienfait pour ce type de public qui sert
déjà l'esprit c'est prouvé
scientifiquement part d'un groupe qui a
fait une étude que il ya 40% de récidive
en bois voilà comme ça alors lui va
rester bien tenu et lui voilà l'idée
lancée que ça et tire bien la partie
d'elton voilà on a inspiré un souffle
elle nous fait tous travailler mais en
douceur et en plus du cancer j'ai une
fibromyalgie et c'est ça m'apporte
beaucoup beaucoup ça me permet de faire
plein de mouvements que je voudrais pas
signés alors qu'il faille pas j'aurai le
temps de le faire mais avec le poignet
gauche le mardi l'équipe se retrouve
pour un cours d'une heure en salle au
programme du renforcement musculaire des
étirements ou encore le travail de
l'équilibré à long terme la coach
sportive aimerait ouvrir son cours aux
malades de sclérose en plaques
d'alzheimer de parkinson est encore de
fibromyalgie
ce numéro le check-up touche à sa fin
avant de nous quitter l'hôtel bien ces
quelques dates santé à ne pas manquer du
14 au 16 avril à magny les hameaux géré
handicap organise la 4e édition des
rencontres de l'autonomie le thème cette
année l'accompagnement des personnes
âgées ou en situation de handicap
au programme des ateliers et des
rencontres pour le programme détaillé et
les inscriptions rendez vous sur le site
internet qui s'affiche le vendredi 17
avril et le vendredi 5 mai des
professionnels propose un atelier
gratuit pour connaître le dos de a à z
un atelier proposé par le service santé
active de voisins-le-bretonneux
rendez-vous de 17h à 19h au centre
alfred de vigny pensez également à vous
inscrire
check up s'est terminé merci de nous
avoir suivis je vous donne rendez-vous
dans un mois et d'ici là
portez vous bien
non